it's pretty surprising that Black Friday
hasn't got its own horror movie
franchise given the terror that shoppers
have to go through every year just a
range a half froze toaster have the arms
of someone less deserving of cheap toast
but whether you love it or loathe it
it's coming and there are some great
gaming deals to wrestle people to the
floor for I'm Dave and this is your
GameSpot news update amazon has
announced that its black friday deals
will start rolling out this coming
Friday November the 20th a variety of
video games and hardware are featured in
the promotion including Xbox one and
PlayStation 4 consoles which will drop
to three hundred dollars instead of 350
the retailer said the $50 discount and
the Xbox one consoles applies to all
consoles while the ps4 deal is only good
for the Uncharted the Nathan Drake
collection system other offers include
the rock band for guitar bundle for $100
Mel Gear Solid 5 the phantom pain for
$35 and Need for Speed for 40 in
addition Amazon says hundreds of digital
PC games will be discounted by as much
as 70%
unfortunately Thomason did not provide
exact timing for when these deals will
be made available the company said only
that the offers were made good at
various times between November 20th and
november 27th will you be scouting the
deals of Black Friday or will you just
stay inside with the windows boarded up
and all the lights off let us know the
comments section below
I'm Dave you can find me on twitter at a
regular Dave and remember to keep it
gamespot.com
for all your gaming news